[Music]
April 2016
orbiting more than 430 miles above the
earth NASA's Landsat 8 satellite
captures a strange set of markings in
the shallows of the Caspian Sea it's
really hard to know what these marks are
are there grooves are they even
underwater or they just reflections off
the top of the surface of the water it's
almost like something is digging into
the sea bottom the photograph is
captured over the chul NE archipelago in
the North Caspian Sea these marks are
several meters to tens of meters across
and very very long propeller marks tend
to be just a few feet long maybe a few
meters long but not kilometers long so I
think if we want to get to the bottom of
this as to why these streaks are
occurring we have to look backwards in
time oceanographers believe that these
marks come from an ice age but that ice
age is more recent than you might think
[Music]
if you look at the satellite picture
from six months earlier you will see
that there is quite a bit of ice cover
over the northern Caspian Sea this ice
is not static you can have either water
currents or you can have tides or you
can have wind pushing the ice along the
coastal ocean there in the Caspian Sea
is rather shallow about three meters
depth and in a shallow region like that
the ice could actually touch the bottom
if the wind starts blowing it will move
it and then will drag the bottom of the
ice and potentially form these types of
streaks the ice forms a temporary kind
of glacier gouging great chunks out of
the sea bottom when it melts into
crystal-clear water
the destruction it has caused is visible
from space
and blown away that it's sea ice
actually I've never seen sea ice scour
seagrass beds like that so this is a
really unusual fine